hi welcome to another episode of the
let's play and I just wondered though
I'm entirely sure that I'm not the first
person to actually thank this but why
are these things even considered I
called let blaze it's like I am playing
the game what I'm not even playing the
game at the moment because that's not
how I roll that's because I want to be
that internet hipster who does unique
things and doesn't want to follow the
crowd is something like but of course
we're all still sheep but that's beside
the point I just feel like why is it
called a let's play if I am actually
doing all of the playing and you are
only doing the watching I think at some
point I always used to wonder why do
people even want to look at let's play
videos of course with my videos I feel
like there's a difference between well
just well I think I've talked about this
earlier on in the series when I talked
about the fact that my Let's Plays
aren't like that kind of let's play that
you watch for the person doing it but
it's also not about the game because a
very important aspect over lets players
have caused the game and how much fun
you have in the game playing all that
but in this case it's more about how you
kind of work with it at least that's how
I feel that I think how some people look
at these videos that I know some people
also look at it to enjoy it I also feel
like some of my videos just have that
kind of teaching role just kind of to
show you guys how I work so actually you
can do that as well and roller coaster
can three and basically it's a learning
process for all of it for all of us have
caused because I can get feedback
feedback on what I'm building on but of
course you if you don't really know how
to do certain things you can always just
look at my video and be like ah that's
how he does it and then still there no
way that I not going to say it like that
honestly be inspired we're all just
stealing different things it's not the
world sir I have obviously stolen all of
these techniques from somebody else of
course that's that's how being inspired
works it's just a euphemism for stealing
things and that's not bad honestly it's
good that you I just voice crack I'm
sorry about that but it's good I guess
stealing things because a just kind of
makes the whole community move
forward and enables everyone to kind of
add that little little building block to
the entire castle that is roller coaster
and three knowledge and custom scenery
and everything around it but I am
digressing that I'm I don't think it's
really a bad thing because I don't
really know what else to talk about and
I kind of don't want to add time music
to my time lapses at this point because
I also feel like me actually talking
about what I'm doing in the game is a
unique selling point though even though
i'm not even talking about the game at
this point so i might want to talk about
the game yeah but it's crashing at the
moment what is this what are you doing I
me let me see for the section this file
actually it doesn't want to work nice so
we're having some technical difficulties
here going to remove that thing from the
project and just edit again this is
armed I am the professional man ok which
firewall which one of you was that kind
of crush to are there we go got it to
work again so what I'm going to I'm
building that stupid thing oh bugger why
am I even ok so yeah basically what I
thought with this I know I'm not even
going to cut this out because I'm going
to be I mean it's gonna be all over and
I need to do everything all over again
it's not gonna going to be timed
correctly and this is just me sitting
here commentating over the [ __ ] that's
happening right now but I just felt at
that point like removing the little
fountain over there and actually adding
a little battle flowers just because I
can and that's basically the explanation
for that now for this I think the
majority of this episode is just me
doing foliage of this freefly coaster or
at least adding extra foliage to it
because I felt like okay I want to have
some really dense foliage and that's for
a couple of reasons actually of course I
wanted to have that that kind of feeling
where you just nearly hit the foliage
because near misses are always good
though they are somewhat risky because
the near miss can always turn into a
Miss and a Miss is really a Miss so to
speak it's not something that you want
to
with your roller coaster but then again
a near miss the nearer the miss the
better it is oh okay that was completely
accidental I did I did not plan that but
that just came out really well Wow and
yeah that's basically about that and
another thing another reason to just add
dense foliage is a very obvious one
while it's not very obvious but very
sneaky in a sense it's just to cover
things up it's a liar I don't want to
have that green background or hey I
don't want people to see that the back
of those buildings or I don't want two
people to see anything so let's just add
crazy dense foliage so nobody can see
anything and hahahahaha now my feeling
looks amazing even though the foliage is
really the only thing that's good and
that well not necessarily like that but
you can cover things up and in this case
I want to cover up that that green
grassland endless kind of plane that
just goes on because this is a
rollercoaster can three and yeah that
you just have to deal with that there
are multiple ways of getting around that
and we still would like some some like
big walls that you could put over there
hey maybe that's an idea I think there's
there's been sky boxes and also I guess
background boxes with like a wall that
you can put along that the while the
borders of the park that would actually
have some nice mountains on it the only
problem that I see with that of course
is the texture would be incredibly large
that would probably crush yeah I don't
know if that would actually work thank
God it's the same reason why note why
there are no sky boxes okay so basically
what I'm doing right now is more foliage
and you might notice that I'm place that
I'm placing beach cross and i'll talk
about this before as well but i'm not
sure whether everyone watches all of my
videos and sometimes i rent in a really
stupid way but beach cross is something
well that i've hated on very often and
it's something that nearly everyone uses
at the moment and i'd rather talk about
that than their boring trees damn just
placing right now because that's just a
tree line at three lines are there to
cover to basically block the sight of
those grasslands so they're not very
interesting the grass however is as in
the beach cross them everything ening
everywhere by the by the way the beach
cross is that small little custom
scenery set with
small grass patches that you kind of
have in on the beach yeah so what with
the thing is with that set is that it's
got it's getting more and more overused
and there's actually two camps within
the community kind of the people over
use it and the people hate it and of
course the people don't know about it
but I'm just gonna leave those guys well
not I'm not going to talk about okay
well I am talking about them right okay
stop that so basically the thing with it
is that many people are placing beach
cross everywhere because there is no
cross in roller coaster can three so you
logically must get the first class you
have go man go back Ross and place it
everywhere but it's not really meant for
that now what I've talked about this
with some people and I came to the
conclusion that it is a great foliage
blender that's also a 10-7 said and it
works really well to place it around
other other foliage and around rocks but
not stand alone as grass so that's why
i'm placing beach cross and right now as
well around all of that foliage it just
kind of helps to blend the foliage into
the grass because otherwise you have I
like sand and then whoa rocks and trees
and there's no real no real well the
fusion between it and the grass kind of
adds that the grass is kind of like okay
we have sand over here we have foliage
over there and we're just kind of going
to mix that very smoothly with a bit of
grass that's basically the idea and it's
somewhat realistic I guess not all cases
but it looks cool so might as well so
that's the entire story about beach
cross and I'm still placing beach cross
everywhere this is a the thing that's
going on right now and is well that's
actually i might as well call this the
beach cross episode is something like
that because i suck at names anyway i I
can't tell you how often I get comments
about names at least not in the comment
section but in skype calls and privately
and all kinds of things and yeah I must
admit I really suck at naming things why
the names of my episodes are so
ridiculously stupid some
times that I'm kind of ashamed of it
sometimes but yeah that that just kind
of happens i guess that happens when
you're me and you're bad at naming
things and so that's pretty much the
story about that and actually speaking
of naming things I'm really bad at
naming multiple things i remember that i
had a coaster called vanilla coconut and
i was like a 13 at the time i was like
oh sounds like a cool coaster name I
don't know why it's and it's an entirely
it is such a stupid name I've no clue
why how I even came up with that and
then somebody left a comment and it was
like vanilla coconut that kind that kind
of sounds like a nice ice cream flavor I
was like damn right that's shooting that
that should be well very nice actually I
reckon that vanilla coconut is actually
a very good combination for ice cream
flavors so the moral of the story is
basically that no matter how bad you are
at naming coasters you can still be
pretty good at designer coming up with
ice-cream flavors I guess though that
was honestly not though the worst name
that I've ever had I've had cranberry
twirl oh now that I come to pick this is
the first time I actually thought about
this but cranberry twirl also sounds
like an ice cream flavor just like have
like vanilla and cranberry and just kind
of twirl it around like it's a
McDonald's mcflurry or something like
that oh wow such ideas and the last name
was eraser I had no clue why did that I
kind of started out I was like okay I'm
gonna call this this coaster it mind
eraser and then I did some research and
it turned out that mind eraser was
awesome and was already a very common
name so I was like okay I don't want to
be common I'll just remove mind and then
I uploaded it as a racer that was a big
mistake I was a stupid name but in
hindsight it was good because we laughed
at it a lot so but yeah I'm not someone
who finds names to it too important for
a coaster it's more about the looks or
anything names well should be good I
guess it's cool when you have a cool
name but when you have a bad name it
doesn't
I'm going to look at the pike but yeah
that's it for this episode so thank you
for watching and see you in the next one
which I'll hopefully stay more on topic
that would be great okay so bye